parliament will vote on the new eu
digital covid certificate
it should allow a gradual return to
easier travel within the eu
by proving the holder has been
vaccinated against covid19
recovered from the infection or recently
tested negative
european cinema lovers and meps have
been casting their votes for the
nominees of the 2021 lux audience award
film prize
another round collective and corpus
christi
the winner will be announced on
wednesday
meps want a binding plan to protect
biodiversity
they'll vote on proposals calling for 30
of the eu's land and sea to be left wild
action to protect pollinators and
targets to bring more biodiversity back
into towns and cities
the european social fund plus supports
the most vulnerable
meps will vote on the new esf plus which
will help combat child poverty
social exclusion and unemployment
especially important due to the impact
of the pandemic
worth more than 79 billion euros global
europe is the eu's new development fund
it will support small businesses through
access to microfinancing
as well as healthcare education and
women's empowerment
in the poorest parts of the world